Shelby starts off this hour in
Springfield Missouri I shall be how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up we have a 2008 Nissan
Rogue that we've had for 10 years and it
just died today the car itself is worth
three thousand dollars only have it paid
off of course the transmission to put
into the car to fix that would cost
$2,900
so do we pay what the car is worth to
fix it or do we spend an extra five
thousand dollars I would take about a
year to pay off to buy it about a
four-year newer car so you have the two
thousand nine hundred dollars to fix the
transformation yes okay but we don't
have the extra five thousand that we
were in about six months to a year why
an extra five thousand just because you
want a better car
no is it smart to fix the car sir DOM
that's only what's that both are dumb
buying a three thousand dollar car with
the money that you have it doesn't seem
like it would lastest with our our we
got four kids you're driving a $3,000
car now yeah then it's broken
yeah so you would say buy a $3,000 car
that might have the same problems as our
current $3,000 car well your $8,000 car
might have the same problems if you
select a bad car a $25,000 car can have
a transmission go out any car can have a
transmission go out on any car runs a
chance of breaking down but if you want
to use all of those emotions to
rationalize going into debt you can but
I'm not going to tell you to I think
it's stupid
I'll walk before I have a car payment
but do we put the money into our broken
car no like would you pay 2,000 into a
car that for 3,000 oh I would sell your
car would sell your car is is for
salvage I would take that money and put
it with the actual cash that you have
and I would not buy a car that had any
debt on it okay now you said you could
pay off a $5,000 additional loan in one
year right
Oh or less okay how quickly could you
pay it off if you went absolutely
bananas
maybe like two months two months mm-hmm
okay well then you could rent a car for
two months and save up the money yeah
okay and then pay cash for a better car
if you want to do it that fast or you
could buy the $3,000 car with how much
money do you actually have in cash
about 3,500 okay and your car probably
bring about 500 as is right uh-huh so
we're buying a $4,000 car with cash and
then save like crazy between now and
Christmas and trade again uh-huh move up
that would that be a wash I mean we
wouldn't I guess we would pay we would
get four thousand if we just bought a
car for four thousand four thousand our
car's not gonna go down much in value in
six months yeah it's pretty well done
uh-huh so it'll hold especially if you
get by decent car you know something
that's decent for $4,000 you're gonna
shop around make sure you get something
that's reliable and it's in better
condition honestly than your robe was
yeah and you can you can buy a lot of
car for $4,000 if you watch what you're
doing we're not worried about the sex
appeal of this car we're worried about
its mechanical substance yes
I don't care if people make fun of its
body I want it to work for those six
months and during those six months you
save up and pay for it now let's back
off just a second okay okay here's the
reasoning behind this so that you
understand why I'm coming down so hard
on it the average car payment in America
today is 507 dollars mm-hmm if the
average person with the average car
payment were to instead invest that
money from age 30 to age 70 instead of
having a car payment their whole life
they would have an excess of five
million dollars translation car payments
are stupid mm-hmm because it costs you
five million dollars in the scope of
your life because you see what I'm
saying so if if the thing you've got to
do then is you got to go okay every time
I have a problem I can't solve it with
debt even if I can in
boats pay it off quickly put your air
quotes up when you do that you know like
mm-hmm pay it off quickly which is
famous last words because usually then
life happens and you don't pay it off
quickly and yeah and drags on out and
you end up living your life from debt to
debt to debt to debt to that from car
payment to car payment to car payment to
car payment from this crisis solved by
debt to that idea solved by debt to oh
we went on vacation we didn't quite pay
forward we got that all last Christmas I
forgot it was in these numbers so it's
debt and you know and like this almost
people live and they live broke and you
work your whole freakin life giving your
money to some stupid bank and that's
what I'm trying to prevent here I want
you to win I want you to be wealthy and
the best way to do that is drive like no
one else so that later you can drive
like no one else today you know what I
Drive anything I want you know when I
drove we went broke a borrowed 1978
Cadillac that the predominant color on
it was bondo and the vinyl roof roof was
loose so when you drove it it filled up
with air it looked like a bondo
parachute coming down the road you might
be a redneck if was written on the side
of it really I drove that car for what
felt like 10 years during one
three-month period that car has scarred
me psychologically where I will never
again in my life do anything that puts
me or my family in a position that we
have to drive some piece of crap like
that again we are going to save we are
going to live on less than we make we
are going to have a plan we are gonna
work like maniacs
we the ramsey's are never going to do
that crap again my family tree has
changed and that's what I want for you
guys instead of living paycheck to
paycheck to paycheck pulling up at a
stoplight comparing payments I'm in cars
with everybody around you those are
broke people at that stoplight they look
good but they're broke people and if
they got a ski boat or a bass boat
behind that nice truck they're really
broke people because they got a $600
payment on a bass boat because the
former bass boat the engine wasn't big
enough and those bass were outrunning
them so they had to get a faster boat
don't we do this stuff we do this stuff
we all do this stuff
so we have to stop I have to go now at
some point we had to break the break the
mold break the cycle break the chains
break the curses of our off our family
tree and say as for me in my house we're
gonna serve the Lord as for me and my
house I don't care what you think about
what I Drive whether you think it's too
nice or not nice enough this is not your
freakin car it's mine shut up I don't
care what you think about what I Drive
I'll tell you who does care my grandkids
mmm-hmm their lives are changed a godly
man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children try that one on
this is the Dave Ramsey show